what is digital art you got it I got it
Oh digital art is just art made in a
digital age we've been looking very much
at the kind of materiality of data and
what that might mean for us as artists
digital art has been around since the
1950s in a sense but not many museums
and galleries have really been focusing
on it as a serious subject matter but I
think in the last 10 years that's really
really changed and many venues around
the world are really having a serious
look at this area and the artists who
are working in that in recent shows at
the V&A the Tate and now the big
exhibition at the Barbican and I think
there'll be many more to come I was the
curator of digital revolution which was
an exhibition which took place at the
Barbican Centre in summer 2014
the exhibition look broadly at digital
creativity so we're looking at the areas
of art design film music and video games
so it was a kind of broad overview of
that subject but also with a sense of
historical context as well one of the
really significant works in the
exhibition is the Pinocchio lamb it's
learning from you how the camera built
into it they can recognize gesture and
facial expression using Arduino and
camera based technology on one level
it's a design item but I think it's sort
of indicating that objects can have real
character and engages in unicycling ways
and for me that that's what makes it off
another key highlight of the exhibition
was Chris milks treachery of the
sanctuary which is this enormous three
screen narrative were using Kinect
camera based technology which allows
visitors to engage with their own shadow
fifteen folds is a digital art gallery
every month we pick a theme and we about
15 artists to interpret the theme in a
form of again when we first started the
project we would go out and approach
artists people whose work we found
online that we really like to interact
with and that's something that we
definitely still do but increasingly we
have people approach us people literally
all over the world are making work like
this and we're one of the very few
online dedicated spaces to give art so
it feels really amazing to give people's
creativity at home that it's totally
deserving of
I guess really we're artists and data is
our material you go to our websites and
look at the work we make you know it's
very easy to describe assistants artists
but as far as we're concerned we're just
artists that work within the
contemporary art context and we really
come out of all of the kinds of concerns
that we share with other artists that
might be working sculpturally or working
with paint or any kind of material in
fact we were thinking well if data is a
material can we draw with it and so this
is us trying to draw with a live news
headline decorative news feeds is an
automatic drawing so it's a kind of
endless animation that uses syndicated
news headlines that RSS feeds and then
takes a news feed at random and displays
it on a screen according to a set of
rules so it's an instruction based
artwork of course news presents itself
as a form of truth and if we just cross
two or three headlines together perhaps
it draws your attention to how what it's
purported to be facts may in fact be
manipulated
there's some great new platforms that
develop to showcase this work one of my
favorites is the creators project which
is a collaboration between Intel and
vice which is a great resource for kind
of new interests to work across the
areas of contemporary art film music a
new platform that's been around only for
a few months now is a space which is
this fantastic platform for new
Commission's and the digital domain and
fantastic space artists to showcase
their latest work which is a free and
very accessible web-based platform there
are huge opportunities for young artists
designers filmmakers going to get
involved in this area if you want to get
involved I think you know blog culture
is so strong at the moment you can set
up your own blog in seconds and start
posting around work and you know you
gain followers and people see your work
and it's also taking an interest in
other people's work and reblogging and
building this sense of community which i
think is really important you don't have
to be alone anymore and I think that
that whole notion of a struggling kind
of artist in the studio kind of waiting
for the next opportunity and again in
the galleries is no more you can really
be out there practicing amongst a very
wide communities and getting an instant
response which is why digital is so
exciting I think
you